لا نقول الا ما يرضي ربنا انا لله وانا
اليه راجعون بحسب بيتي وبيت اولادي وبيت
اولادي المتزوجين عرسان جداد عرايس سنتين
ما دقن من فرحه الحياه الا ايام معدوده
عفشه عزاله بيوتهن حطن احلامن كلهن في
هالبيت عروستين لسه في مقبل شبابه ببن
حياه اطفالي لسه بنوا حياه بدهم احنا شعب
بنحب الحياه احنا شعب بنحب الحياه بنحب
نعيش بنحب نفرح بنحب ننبسط
ما بنحبش الدمار لحدا حتى لو اسونا ما
بنحب الدمار ولا بنحب الموت احنا شعب بدنا
نعيش رغما عنهم باذن الله احنا شعب لا
نموت والله لو وضعونا في القبور احنا شعب
لا يموت احنا مثل شجر الصبار راسخين
ثابتين باذن الله تعالى يعملوا اللي بدهم
يعملوه قسما بالله لنعيد ونبنيها احسن من
اول قسما بالذي اجرى البحار والانهار قسما
بالذي رفع السماوات بلا عمد ستبنى حي
الندى باذن الله وسنعود اليها رغما عنهم
وسنعود الى ديارنا وسنعود الى زكيم اللي
اخذوها باذن الله تعالى سنرجع زكيم هي
هربيا وصيه ابوي وصيه جدادي وصيتي لاولادي
ارجعوا يا امي وحررها لو دمكم سال بركان
ارجعوا حرروا كل بلادنا وعرايس اولادي
باذن الله سينجب الذريه الصالحه اللي تعمر
ارض فلسطين وان شاء الله يكونوا من حفظه
كتاب الله ومن حمله القران باذن الله اللي
بده ينير طريقنا احنا لا نهزم والله لا
نهزم ولو ظل فينا اصغ
ان شاء ان شاء الله ين بقوه الله
وقدره